have you heard the new terms spornosexual
yes spornosexuals are the new metrosexuals
the Mark Simpson who the journalist who
coined the term metrosexual and the
Israeli guy that started
private 10 years ago cared what they
look like they wore clothes that were a
little tighter
kind of a little gayer but they were gay
they were straight guy that thing to
look a little gayer
put your poll more product in their back
anything I kept feeling good about my
hair
grade I but now
he's now talking about Bordeaux sexual
than this is this new
group man who works who are hyper sexual
and body obsessed we got an explanation
up the
spore no sexual with their painstakingly
pumped and chisel body's muscle
enhancing tattoos piercings
adorable beards and plunging neckline
did eye-catching we clear that the
second generation
Metro sexuality is less about clothes
that it was for the first
their own bodies more than clobber and
product had become the ultimate
accessories fashioning them at the jam
into a hot commodity won the day share
and compare
in an online marketplace so the online
marketplace that you talk about a course
in social media that people are
taken the you know LP's everywhere at
the gym perfect body tattoo
and tight haircut Blalock I am
is this the the is the gay agenda
it work with are they hurting all the
straight people gay is that happening
here get yeah
children but yeah fantastic I'm I think
the first ball
it's a great definition terrible name
yet don't like you have some sort of
that
spore induced STD yeah but God bless
export a sexual the first thing I
thought I mean you know my golden
nothing at Dartmouth's more neck
so I thought it was someone that said
%uh with the art there perhaps
which it might be a good idea netsetter
can't live in a world that wonderful
there is no utopia were everywhere
esparto thank you everyone up that they
are very good
but I think this is absolutely accurate
is it bad to me that this
hit the word hipsters so played out I
don't think that definition early means
anything anymore
I think it's the sport is actually got
barely got the poll lunging neckline
yeah
and you have all your glamour muscles
exactly where you want them
you probably can actually lift something
heavy but you've got great right
somewhat this is accurate right right
well this reminds me of my little with
value it at all these guys that have
huge muscles and they probably couldn't
throw a ball
four feet away yeah it's because it's
all about the visual
quoted you do you like these kinda guy I
love it on rather than if he used to not
wear clothes anymore
yeah wants to wear clothes but I have
James Franco to wholeness Jogia
humans on Instagram I thought something
that the day where
now you know you will speed on you where
3.0 now
it's like 15 coming up this is like a
ball okay
it like fat yet to those other ones like
the one we're close
the water softener absent arms and the
nipple that their
whatever for you I didn't think on the
neck could go down to your ankle right
led what is the National Parole blood
what is it love it
yeah well do you think there's some
element a bit
that men lose a little something
something that women love about men and
maybe that when they're so into
themselves numero is
complaining every second every is about
the man complaining the white scared
about what your hair battle ahead now
matter doing it now and then
the other good players why why did God
it takes longer to get ready tonight
right
and I mean that for me that's impossible
because I mean clearly this took know
what I want to thank you
fine with that that's how comfortable
but I think that
I think there that you're both reagan
gets but I can't. it's fun to look at
its fun to make fun of its fun to talk
about
it's fun to see pictures I love but in
general do I
feel like I'm gonna connect to somebody
who is just like all
oiled up probably not like I but I love
the conversation
yeah what would you think what the base
after this if it started you had regular
guys that you had the metro sexual now
we got this morn a sec I'm easy to just
everyone's important
next that well and that that we might 30
but unbowed are both about something
that you gave us a rolled into bed
those growth for roadway you have to
write I think
what it does is it breeds more narcissus
about and
the Instagram the self be the us either
everything is that he
isn't breen I did it's all about me
me look at my have this is over the top
is over the top